here's an example okay
uh it's famous space time okay
and uh you have two versions of space
and we have the ridiculous 2d space time
and a ridiculous 3d space time and you
can see that one is sitting on top of
space time the other one has is drawing
space-time towards its center in this
case the earth right and the question is
these two cannot both be right
and so these people put these things out
there and they get thousands of hits and
people say oh and on oh that's so great
that's evanta and they don't even know
what they're staring at they don't even
know if this matches in any way
you know what einstein said and it turns
out that they don't because einstein
first of all said that you know you can
only apply relativity out there and a
lot of these folks don't know it you
know there's this fellow who uh goes out
there and um says that he's gonna prove
warped space in his basement and he goes
in there he does the cavendish
experiment in his basement he says oh i
proved uh that uh you know that let me
put this out of here for a second and i
approved warp space in my basement
no you can't space time doesn't work
down here i can't i can't explain using
einstein's equations okay i cannot
explain why this pencil this pen drops
to the table i cannot explain it with i
cannot do i cannot apply einstein's
equation here you can only apply
einstein's equation with big masses out
there in the global universe
you cannot you cannot say that space is
so warped here that this falls at that
rate that that's why it's falling
okay and so again these people have
these notions let me get it back up here
now
okay and one guy says 3d spacetime no
that's not what einstein said so so this
guy thinks he's very smart because he's
oh i figured out how space-time really
works no space-time works like the one
on the left for otherwise mercury's
orbit which is up there in the center uh
wouldn't work
you know mercury's orbit the one uh
einstein applied this theory too works
like the 2d space time the ridiculous 2d
space time on the left the
two-dimensional one okay so which one
should you choose should you go with one
on the right which is a totally
different mechanism than the one on the
left that's the million dollar question
well you know i'm a guy who believes in
authority and uh and in um
democracy people who vote majority rule
everybody votes for flat earth i'll be a
flatter third then okay i gotta be a
flat earther because majority rules
right and so i'm gonna go with the head
honchos of mathematical physics and here
we have one his name is brian green and
this is his version which is the one on
the left that you just saw okay that's
his version of why the moon doesn't fly
out of the solar system very
straightforward okay we have a
depression
you know this uh surrealistic depression
a two-dimensional cross-section of
space-time i guess and the moon doesn't
fly away because it is trapped within
that depression like a little ball
rolling around a roulette okay so i
don't know what part you didn't
understand there because it's very
straightforward it's illustrated and he
brian green is a
phd right a celebrity etc etc okay so he
should know okay so you got to follow
him because he's
you know he knows his stuff he's done
all that math he should know whether the
earth
or the moon rolls around
you know a depression caused by the
earth or whether it's being pointed
towards the center of the earth and to
the center of the moon into the center
of the sun which way does uh
the space-time gravity work okay so you
so you got to figure out which other two
those two can't be both right okay
and just to get to rub it in i'm gonna
go also with another source which is
also um
authoritative okay so here it is that's
nasa nasa also has the earth weighing
down the canvas not uh the canvas uh
being dragged into the center of the
earth okay so we have to go with this
version of gravity according to einstein
according to the folks in nasa and all
the phd's out there right who do with do
um mathematical physics we have to go
with their version and not to the
people who you know think they invented
something new by pointing the
by drawing the fishnet inside the earth
okay okay so what is the mechanism why
doesn't the earth fly out of the solar
system why doesn't the moon fly out of
the earth orbit okay what's keeping it
there and here we have it okay this is
this is what the theory says
the irrational theory of math of uh
general relativity says here it is okay
this is the curve wall of time they say
time is a physical object like a wall
the earth
rolls around or slides along this curve
and that's why it doesn't fly out of the
solar system very very similar to the
analogy of a roulette you know you have
the little ball going around the
roulette why doesn't it fly out of there
uh because it's got this this wall
that's preventing the little ball from
flying out and this is no different okay
so it's the roulette mechanism
and then uh what these people say is you
know when you show them this you say
well is this what you're saying you're
saying time is warped uh are you saying
there's a canvas there that comes
against the skin of the planet
you know is is our planet rolling or
scraping
around that depression is that why the
earth doesn't fly out because that's
what they've explained that's what they
illustrated that's what they told you
objectively
and they said bill you're not supposed
to take the analogy literally
and here this is what they show you okay
they show you this little uh cartoon
they said understanding gravity
space-time is like a rubber sheet
massive objects distort the sheet and
wait they distort it because they're
pulled down by what and the teacher you
know loses patience says spacetime is
like the set of equations for which any
analogy must be an approximation
wrong okay it's not that it's an analogy
you have to explain the mechanism of why
the earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system if you're going to go in there
and say well there's a depression and
the earth rolls around it and blah blah
blah and then at the end of your class
you say oh by the way that was only an
analogy there is no depression there is
not nothing coming up against the skin
of the earth then what have you said
what is your mechanism
okay so this is the issue these people
give you a two hour explanation they
show you the pictures they describe the
pictures they show you the whole works
they explain the mechanism you say okay
i understood it because you see all the
objects on the screen or wherever and
then they say oh by the way that that
depression that's not there it's just an
analogy you're not supposed to take it
literally
great
okay so here we have
the earth because you know you're saying
okay but they were able to explain many
things with this okay for example
certain orbits and so on with these
equations not explain them but really
describe them okay and the question is
does the mechanism that general
relativity that mr einstein proposed
is it rational
can you use this to
simulate what's out there
and they say yeah it is because see we
were able to explain like in this that's
all i mentioned that he says that
there's no planet called vulcan that's
close to
the sun you know somewhere between uh
mercury and the sun because they have to
try to explain the orbit of mercury and
liveria try to explain that and he
couldn't he died he thought there was a
planet there
which was later named vulcan because
he's the guy who discovered you know the
uh neptune and so they said just like he
did that math and figured out neptune
maybe we can figure out you know um
what is it
that there's a little planet there that
we can't see very well that's between
the earth and the sun and he says thanks
to general relativity we didn't need
that planet we could explain the orbit
of um mercury
uh just with equations
and what he doesn't understand this
fellow and 99 of humanity out there is
that mathematics is tautology
what they do is they make an equation
that describes what they're observing
so it better be a tactology if the
equation is correct
it's just a tautology it means that
you're making a tailor-made equation so
that it fits the observation
and that's what einstein did with
mercury he just went in there put some
variables in there he said see if we put
this this in this way
then we can we can explain
the orbit
and and what is einstein's equation for
mercury is that it's a point mass okay
to use that terminology it's a point
mass it describes the motion of a point
mass around the sun that's what
einstein's equation does
that's different than newton's which
said look there's two objects
and they attract uh according to the
inverse uh square of the distance okay
so so the notions are different and in
the case of ions it's just a point mass
that moves around the sun and you're
describing that path
so it is a tautology that's why it works
more or less you know maybe there's a i
think it's not perfect on the money but
it uh pretty much resembles what mercury
does that's a description we still don't
know the mechanism why does mercury
where does the mercury fly out of the
solar system and that's when they bring
in the canvas okay so what's the problem
with the canvas why is it irrational
okay why does it explain it explains
mercury great i'll i'll concede
explains mercury rolling around the sun
what doesn't it explain which is 99 of
the other stuff and here's what it does
not explain okay here we have uh the
earth and the moon rolling around the
sun okay so we have the moon the sun
weighing down the canvas okay and then
around that we have the earth it also
weighs its little canvas which is
rolling around the other canvas right
and the moon has to roll around the
canvas that the earth created okay so
far so good they're both uh the can the
two canvases the one for the
sun and the earth in fact even for the
moon they all point downwards okay and
we don't know why they point downwards
but we're not going to get into that
right now i just want you to focus on
the fact that the um
fish nets right the canvases okay
they're all uh parallel the one for the
earth the one for the moon and the one
for the sun they're all pretty much
parallel they're in the same direction
okay what's the problem with this well
the problem with this is here okay
here you have the earth on the upper
right and that's correct they all are
parallel with the
ecliptic essentially right in other
words the canvas there matches the one
the canvas of the sun
but that doesn't happen with uranus and
it's big moon uh oberon okay oberon goes
uh around the equator of
uranus but uranus is on its side
uranus uh twirls towards the sun all
these are views from the sun by the way
okay so you have um
oberon the biggest moon of uranus and
it's going towards in the direction of
the sun over the head of uh uranus which
is on its side it's in other words
oberyn's running around its equator the
north south is in the east-west
direction
okay so jupiter is on its side and it
has to be pushing the canvas towards the
side i chose one side it could be
towards the other side but it doesn't
matter it would point east in this case
or it could point west in order for
oberon to
orbit the
uranus the way it does
okay so we have a problem because the
earth weighs it downwards and the moon
waves our moon weighs it down in
networks because they all are parallel
with the sun weighing no cannabis
downwards but uh oberon and uranus
falsify that
you know oberon uh twirls towards the
sun and so does uh uranus it's north and
south pole or sideways and what happens
with uh pluto and with sharon it's the
biggest moon well again you see there it
forms a bullseye pattern as seen from
the sun
okay so pluto would have to uh push the
canvas outwards or inwards towards the
sun in order for sharon to orbit the way
it does you know in a bullseye pattern
as seen from the sun
so so the problem with einstein's
explanation is that it cannot explain
these three different mechanisms
you know with its canvas analogy
you know how do you explain it with a
with a canvas analogy if if the uh sun
weighs it downwards why would ju why
would uh uranus
push the camera sidewards and why would
uh pluto push it outwards that's the
issue
and here let me um
let me uh bring this other give me a
second here
this is a summary of what einstein's
theory is his explanation his physical
interpretation of how these moons work
okay you see the sun weighs the canvas
downwards you can see the white arrows
in below each one of the suns there okay
in the case of the earth no problem
everybody points downwards in the case
of
uranus
it has to push the canvas sidewards in
order for oberon to twirl around the
canvas the roulette mechanism
over the
top and towards the sun and in the case
of pluto
uh pluto would have to push it outwards
or inwards towards the sun in order for
sharon to twirl around in the direction
in which it does
so einstein's theory does not work his
explanation does not work for a
three-body system
okay
and so here they have all these um uh
tests of relativity that you'll find out
there in the wikipedia and they say all
these confirm relativity
general relativity okay and maybe they
should include you know the
uh one is i mean there's several i mean
i'm just pointing to one problem there
which is you know in the direction in
which the moons orbit
and einstein cannot explain that with
his
um you know with his mechanism the
mechanism that he proposes for gravity
he cannot explain it a three-body system
okay so this is the issue and they
should include that see they never
include that within the failures of
general relativity they say everything's
been confirmed
you know and uh they
what are you gonna confirm for a black
hole zero dimensional nothing
what confirmation do you have there
you know what proof do you have
that there is a zero dimensional matter
less meaning massless
entity out there that's moving stars
around
dark matter
what have you confirmed about dark
matter
that there's this invisible variable
that you put in an equation
and that you're looking for now in the
night sky again all these are failures
of general relativity and nobody
mentions that they just
mention stuff that they measure and they
say oh we've proven everything in fact
they put detection of black holes they
show that ridiculous picture that they
published and they got so many kudos for
okay so um
what's the underlying problem of all
this well the underlying problem is that
mathematical physics mathematics
does not use physical objects
and why don't they use objects well
because the mathematicians never define
what an object is they have no use for
objects they only deal with equations
with behaviors and they don't care about
you know
objects they do not care about
simulating things with objects and you
can see where the problem is if you go
through the literature
any literature scientific so-called
scientific literature out there like i
do you know read papers
and what you will never find
rarely is i think almost never is a
picture
here we have physics which should be a
discipline that should be full of
pictures you should have all these
pictures showing
uh mechanisms and so on and you go to
these
uh so-called scientific literature and
all you find is equations you'll never
find a picture
why because it's um
outside of their uh
job descriptions it below their pay
grade to put pictures in a uh in a in an
article in a paper
and so this is where the problem is you
know physics uh we say it's causes and
mechanisms the only way you can explain
a cause or a mechanism is if you have
objects because you have to simulate it
with some kind of object you got to show
us the mechanism what mechanism what
mechanism are you going to show if you
just put an equation what have you shown
okay you haven't shown a mechanism all
you have is a description a mathematical
description of you know something you
measured
you know but never never an explanation
of what caused that to happen that's the
issue and so no uh physically the
language of physics is not mathematic
mathematics okay if
uh physics has to do with explanations
of mechanisms and if it does then the
language of physics is illustration you
have to illustrate you have to
illustrate the singularity at the
beginning of time big bang you have to
illustrate dark matter and show us how
it produces this mass that in other
words how does it keep that
star in the outside from going faster
you can't just say there's more mass
there because that's it this just as a
description you haven't told me the
mechanism what causes it to go faster
all you have is a description of the
fact that you know there's more mass and
according to the equation it should go
faster that's all you've told me you
haven't told me anything about what is
the mechanism in fact they used
newtonian uh the law for that you know
the gravitational law and newton said
you know
fingo nun hypothesis in other words he
said i have no i propose i have no
hypothesis no theory he had no
explanation for how that works
okay
okay so um
you need objects you need objects to
explain a mechanism and i'll give you an
example here okay
um
i need to explain to you how the steam
engine works
you know a long time ago
uh should be straightforward okay and
here it is i illustrate it for you okay
so that you can understand the mechanism
just by watching the movie and here it
is okay
feed coal into the furnace team pushes
the piston upwards okay
introduce cold water and the piston
comes downwards now how difficult can
that be anyone who watches this should
say okay i understand how the steam
engine works okay why it goes up and
down because you have that furnace at
the bottom steam pushes it upwards cold
water pushes it downwards okay
straightforward
did i need any mass do i need to know
how much energy do i need to know mass
or field or
or any of those parameters do i need to
know force no i'm just trying to figure
out what the mechanism is and a 10 year
old can tell you what the mechanism is
here you know he pushes it up cold water
pushes it down we're done
see how easy it was no math no no
nothing that's what we want for gravity
okay we want an explanation like this a
baby one one that a 10 year old can
understand what did i say if you can't
explain it to a 10 year old you don't
know it well enough or you don't know it
at all and find one says something
similar or to a barmaid okay so this is
the issue the issue is we want an
explanation for what causes the pen to
go down
if that's science we haven't made any
progress in the last two and five
hundred years and we also need proposed
irrationalities in the last two hundred
years
opposite of what this fellow said right
okay so here i'm going to show you a
little picture which i put in in the uh
science series okay and
i want you to tell me objectively okay
what caused the window to break okay see
if you can figure it out i mean this is
difficult i know for some of you who are
not used to seeing images watching
movies it's very hard on your eyes or
whatever okay so here it is
so you have to tell me what caused the
window to break here it is again just in
case you missed it felix revolves it and
throws it in
looks like
i think anyone on the planet would say
that a horseshoe went through the window
that's what broke the glass
okay was it difficult one more time just
in case you missed it okay
now this is what we call objectivity
i should get every person on the planet
who is more or less saying right
and um and ask them how did the window
break
and the person should say
that window that specific window person
should say you know horseshoe went
through the window and broke the window
i'm not asking them anything about mass
and force and energy
uh whether he ate an ice cream i'm not
asking
stuff out of the ordinary i'm asking how
did the window break objectively what
did you see
every person should answer the same
thing
that's known as objective
and why we could see it because we could
see every single object
in the movie we could see the horseshoe
we could see the glass we could see you
know felix waving this horse you around
the horseshoe goes through the window
and breaks it every person on earth
should answer the same thing anyone who
doesn't has a mental problem
what did this person answer
this is this is what he answered
let me put this up here
he said no one can objectively tell you
what happened there
especially seeing as they're just
cartoons
i couldn't believe his answer
so if i asked a ten-year-old you know
what are you seeing there uh 10 year old
uh what's happening there and i think if
i go to kindergarten all the kids would
say well bugs bunny jumped or dived
you know he dove into
a rabbit hole that's what they would say
that's what you're staring at that's
objectively what's there
but he says he can't tell me objectively
what's there because it's a cartoon
that was his answer i couldn't believe
it
[Laughter]
okay but you see what kind of people
you're dealing with
uh either they're making themselves hard
to catch or they don't want to be
um
you know caught in their lies or in
their contradictions so they say even
more dumb things like you know i can't
tell you because it's a cartoon i can't
tell you why the window broke i can't
tell you uh that uh
what is it bugs uh dove into his
his uh hole because it's a cartoon
and this is the problem with these
people okay so now someone comes to you
okay someone comes to you he's a
religious folk someone from the
uh traditional religions and he says
i've got a theory of gravity
okay what's your theory of gravity
it says here i'm saying that angels
mediate gravity
i say that angels carry astronauts to
earth they uh force angels that are here
they force the pin to fall and so on
so i'm a little skeptical i'd have to
see it
okay i've illustrated it for you here it
is i'm gonna show you okay and so here
he puts this up there for you okay so
that you can verify what he's saying the
mechanism and here you have the angel
carrying the you know astronaut to earth
he says that's how gravity works
according to me
and you might go in there and say well
you know i don't believe in your theory
you know what what experiments have you
run you know i don't believe in angels i
don't even believe in god you know so
you know i think you're wrong
you know have you done any experiment
what's the equation uh can you show me
something
wrong questions
wrong questions the person is saying
giving you a mechanism he's telling you
a mechanism of how he thinks what he
proposes of how gravity works
we're not asking you to believe in his
theory
we're not asking you to what's the
evidence how many people have voted for
your theory we don't care about any of
that we want to understand what's in his
mind as far as what he proposes for the
mechanism of gravity
and there he's shown he's saying angels
carry it down to earth
and the question is did you understand
the mechanism that he's proposing
that's the question
and if you didn't understand it and you
say well you know it's just a cartoon
anyways
well then you got a problem you got a
mental problem you got a mental problem
because the question is do you
understand the mechanism that he's
proposing
that's the question that's what's before
us we're not talking about evidence
we're not talking about who believes in
it we're looking at the mechanism okay
so now there's another fellow he comes
up and he says look i've got a
theory of gravity
okay what's your theory
well i say that all atoms in the
universe are interconnected
and uh so every atom from the earth is
connected to the astronaut
and so as he approaches the earth he
ropes in this case right they fan out
all these elongated entities
fan out
and he accelerates ever at a faster rate
so he goes faster faster faster we call
that acceleration that's the
acceleration of gravity
well can you illustrate
that mechanism for me yeah sure and here
the felt goes in there and he
illustrates it for you and he says here
it is okay
he didn't draw all the uh
elegated objects there because it would
be a gazillions he just
you know illustrated a few so that you
can understand the mechanism of what is
bringing the
uh astronaut to earth why he falls to
earth and not to you know to outer space
why because the earth is very close by
again and consistent consistent with
newton's equation so we're all safe
there okay so the fellow falls to earth
the astronaut falls the earth because
every atom in his body is bound to every
atom that comprises the earth that's the
theory
okay and the question is did you
understand the theory
and the guy says well i don't believe in
your
theory i don't see any ropes or or uh
anything you know uh between any two
atoms i can't touch them
so where did you come up with this
and why can't i touch them and so on you
know and so the issue is did you
understand the mechanism
that's the only question the question
did you understand the mechanism
and the guy said no i don't understand
because it's a cartoon
okay what are you gonna do the guy
doesn't understand because it's a
cartoon we're asking him to understand
why the window broke he doesn't
understand it against a cartoon he
doesn't understand why uh that bugs dove
into his hole because you know it's just
a cartoon he doesn't understand that the
angel carried the astronaut to earth
because that's just a cartoon and he
doesn't understand the ropes because uh
he says that's a cartoon
and so uh you know we're talking about
mechanisms here and he doesn't
understand it yet he understood probably
uh i think you know the steam engine
and he said why did you understand that
that was a cartoon too
yeah but that's real and i prove it and
i've got evidence and everybody voted
for it
so he believes on the basis of authority
because that's a cartoon too that was a
drawing
and so this is the issue the issue is
people are confusing belief
with objectivity what we have in front
of us if i ask every person on earth
what did you just see
they should all say any rational human
being should say the astronaut every
atom in his body was tied to every atom
on earth and so he fell because you know
the ropes got closer to the earth now
maybe they're elastic we don't
understand that yet there are other
problems but the issue is they should be
able to give you a general term that the
astronaut fell to earth because every
atom in his body is bound to every atom
on earth he's tied to the earth that's
the mechanism now we can go into more
detail later on but the issue is
we're talking about mechanisms here
whether you understand the mechanism
proposed if you don't well we have to
say a little more maybe so that you
understand it better but to say well i
can't understand because it's a cartoon
well not very smart
and you say well where'd you get that
anyways i mean where'd you come up with
all this nonsense about you know uh all
atoms being interconnected and so on
well here it is okay here's for those
who want proof and evidence we don't
deal with this in science but here you
have proof evidence authority all the
stuff that you always wanted okay here
you have uh mr richard miller professor
at berkeley says so for example if you
have the earth there's a big mass here
and you have you with your little mass
here every atom on earth is pulling on
every atom of you you're also pulling on
it the amazing thing about gravity is
that it goes right through things
okay
so yeah if every atom on you of you is
pulling on every atom on earth and vice
versa it means every atom of you is
connected physically connected to every
atom on earth because otherwise you're
introducing black magic
you're saying that
when adam pulls on you but there's no
connection no physical entity between
you that's what you're saying
okay
so
this is the issue the issue is mechanism
and uh this person you know this
individual apparently does not
understand that he thinks that science
is about just math and authority and
just believing in what the
people in cambridge and oxford and
harvard and caltech
you know just feed them
and hopefully not hopefully science is
about like what he did here questioning
uh the instructor or the theorist or
whoever questioned them
and the question did he ever question
his instructors his teachers or what he
read did he ever question that and or
did he just accept and say well you know
black holes have been proven so yeah uh
i'll accept that and i'll accept dark
matter and i'll accept dark energy and
that a particle can be in two places at
once and blah blah blah blah blah why
because it's being fed to him as proof
and truth and fact that's the only
reason he believes in it he has no
argument i mean he could just as well
raise the arguments he raised in my
videos against those are those uh
theories why did he ever do that and i'm
i'm almost sure he did because you know
you find people like joe rogan and so on
they they interview all these people uh
the celebrities of math and they tell me
there's several universes and uh the
particles come out of nothing
and we have all these black holes and
dark matter out there
and he never questioned it's like oh
okay that's nice that's interesting then
he brings another celebrity who tells
them the same thing
and they'll just accept it and accept it
and accept it and accept it no one
questions it what do you mean black hole
what do you mean that particles can come
out of the void what do you mean that a
particle can be a two places at once
nobody questions that they just accept
it because it comes through the
channel of
authority that's what it's called